joe biden volverá a la casa blanca esta
vez como inquilino tras ser electo
presidente de eeuu ante un público
eufórico el líder demócrata presentó su
discurso de victoria tras unas
elecciones que pusieron en vilo al país
durante cuatro días el pueblo de esta
nación ha hablado
pero ellos nos entregaron un mensaje una
victoria clara hemos ganado con la mayor
cantidad de votos troche que alguna vez
votada del sur en la historia del país
74 millones
bardem se refirió a las infundadas
acusaciones de fraude por parte del
presidente de donald trump y sus
seguidores y pidió reconciliación es
momento de pasar un lado la retórica
agresiva a bajar la temperatura vernos
el uno al otro escucharnos el uno al
otro de nuevo y para lograr progreso
debemos dejar de tener trata de nuestros
oponentes como nuestros enemigos ellos
no son nuestros enemigos son
estadounidenses entre los pilares de su
agenda baiden resaltó la lucha contra el
kobe 19 el cambio climático y el racismo
el líder demócrata también halagó a su
compañera de fórmula
quien se convirtió en la primera mujer
en llegar a la vicepresidencia de
estados unidos además de ser afro y
tener descendencia india
baby the first mensajes han habido manos
aunque sea la primera mujer en este
cargo no será la última
[Aplausos]
watson porque cada niña que está viendo
esto podrá ver que este es un país de
posibilidades aunque aún faltan más de
dos meses para su posición el equipo
baiden harris ya anunció sus planes para
poner su agenda en marcha pero el
proceso de transición amenaza con
complicarse teniendo un presidente
saliente que todavía no contempla dejar
la casa blanca